When we get a new piece of equipment or
accessory, we generally take it out of
the box and start using it. But there's
important documentation contained in
those packing materials. If you look
around, you'll probably find a material
safety data sheet or an MSDS.
This is a document required by the
United States Department of Labor
Occupational Safety and Health
Administration or OSHA. If you want more
information on OSHA, you can find it on
their website at osha.gov.
gov. You might also hear this referred
to as a safety data sheet or SDS. It is
exactly the same thing as a material
safety data sheet. There's just
different names that we use depending on
where you are in the world. This
document provides you with all of the
hazard and safety information associated
with this product. So any products that
have hazardous materials, such as toner
cartridges, ink cartridges, or
batteries, are all subject to these
material safety data sheets.
You'll see that a great deal of
information is included on this MSDS,
including the company and product
information. For example, the toner
cartridge and who made it, the
composition and ingredients of that
particular product, any hazard
information, first aid measures,
firefighting measures, and so on.
Anything regarding the health and safety
of the people using this product is
documented in this material safety data
sheet.
We use a lot of batteries in it. Not
just the batteries that we have for our
laptops and mobile devices, but we also
have a lot of batteries that we use
inside of our uninterruptible power
supplies or our UPS. There might be one
or many of these battery types inside of
those UPS systems. And of course, we
need to understand how to properly
dispose of all of these batteries. The
same thing applies for the toner
cartridges that we use in our printers.
We need to dispose of these properly.
And in many cases, the printer
manufacturer has a recycle program and
they include a return label in the box
with the toner. That's not the case with
every toner cartridge, and you may find
that some local office supply houses
will provide you with a discount if you
bring in used toner cartridges. If
you're not able to recycle or trade in
these cartridges for a discount, you
might want to refer back to your
material safety data sheet to determine
the best way to dispose of these toner
cartridges. You should certainly not
throw away batteries and toner in your
normal garbage. You should always
dispose of hazardous materials at the
proper location near you.
We also have to think about the
environment that we have inside of our
work areas, specifically room control
for temperature. All of these powered
devices create heat in the memory and
the CPU of these systems. So, we need to
make sure that we have the proper
cooling so that they work at an optimal
temperature. The same thing applies for
humidity. Although we can minimize
electrostatic discharge by having high
humidity levels, that also makes your
work area a bit uncomfortable. We need
to find the right balance between
temperature and humidity level. But if
you keep the humidity at about 50%,
that's a good number to strive to. And
of course, if we're cleaning out dusty
computers and printers with a lot of
paper inside of it, then we'll want to
have proper ventilation in our work
area. But if you're working with very
dusty systems, you may want to make sure
that you're using a vacuum if it's
inside of the building. And it may be
more appropriate to take the computer
outside of the building to use
compressed air to clean out all of that
dust.
We often think of a UPS as a single unit
that sits under our desk or it slides
into a rack. But in an entire building,
a UPS can be quite large, an entire room
full of nothing but batteries. It's
important to know how to manage,
maintain, and keep all of these systems
up to date and running well. We have to
use these UPS systems for our backup
power in case we lose main power to our
facility. And of course, if you have
undervoltage events or power surges,
your UPS can help protect you against
those as well. You may be using a
standby UPS that switches over from
regular power to the battery source.
There's usually a small delay during
that switching time frame. You might be
using a line interactive UPS. So as you
lose voltage on the main line, your
battery begins to provide additional
power. Or perhaps you have an online UPS
where you're always running from the
battery and the main power is simply
there to continue to charge all of those
batteries. The UPS, of course, is
providing more than simply power for
your computer. It may have features that
provide auto shutdown when you're not
anywhere nearby. You may be able to get
different sizes of UPS to provide
different capacities of power. The
number of outlets on the UPS can also be
customized, so you get a system that can
support many different units. And phone
line and Ethernet power suppression is
often built into a number of these
uninterruptible power supplies.
If you don't need standby power, but you
would like to make sure that you're
using the cleanest power possible, you
might want to install a surge
suppressor. During the day, your power
voltage goes up and down. There are
spikes and noise on the line. And
occasionally, there will be a storm that
adds additional noise to the power
source. A surge suppressor will notice
these spikes occurring and will take any
excess voltage and redirect it to the
ground. Many surge suppressors also
include noise filters to remove noise
from the electrical line. And they work
by filtering a certain decel level of
noise at a specified frequency. This
means a surge suppressor with a higher
decibel rating will be able to filter
more line noise.
We also have to think about how the
surge suppressor will handle spikes. If
you get a large amount of voltage at one
time, you can absorb that surge. And
most suppressors will tell you just how
many jewels they're able to suppress.
200 jewels is good, 400 is better, but
the best suppressors are over 600 jewels
of spike suppression. Along the same
lines, there is a surge amp rating
associated with these suppressors. If
you get a higher amp rating, it's a
better quality suppressor. And another
good specification to look for on your
surge suppressor is a UL1449
voltage let through rating. You'll see
suppressors rated at 500, 400, and 330
volts. And the lower you get with these
values, the better quality suppressor.